voici la dernière ligne de francs
nous sommes au pont dire pin c'est la
dernière lille de front sur le nord
ouest avec une avance et on entend en
permanence des explosions
une avancée massive des forces russes de
l'autre côté de ce pont qui a été saboté
sciemment par les forces du crédit est
né hier matin
voilà la réalité de l'offensive russe il
ya des centaines d'habitants pouvait
voir une
des gens manifestement âgées on se
demande en quoi ces gens âgés peuvent
poser un problème à moscou
moi je suivais genève
mais un jour le trajet français
je voudrais dire à tous les ukrainiens
qui sont actuellement en france de ne
pas avoir peur tout va bien nous allons
vaincre c'est une certitude bientôt vous
pourrez revenir dans vos foyers français
et toi tu vas revenir en france où tu te
bats ici jusqu'à la fin
tel moyen payé dans le monde les forces
russes sont d'après les informations des
volontaires et des soldats ukrainien sur
place sont à un petit kilomètre là il
laisse passer depuis le corridor
humanitaire
l'ensemble des habitants d'irbine qui
continuent d'échapper à cette emprise et
les combats on peut entendre un peu
partout ici dans cette enclave et bien
des combats des tirs d'artillerie et de
mortiers et des explosions qui sont de
plus en plus importante et surtout
incessantes
et là les explosions savvis quoi lasser
les russes qui bombarde il bombarde quoi
vous savez
pour le moment c'est très difficile de
comprendre d'où ça
mais nous
nous doit
on doit
faire l'offensive c'est notre
obligatoires